I'm not sure about this plan because
it's not really a plan it's a ruse
that's the part I don't like you and I
are two highly ranked members of
Starfleet doing a routine surprise
inspection we could be called Marshall
for this you could lose everything you
work for only if we get caught you got
to sell this
come on Admiral show me your inspection
face give me one of those rigid
disapproving sour Expressions you're
famous for
there it is there it is there it is
he just said show me your inspection
face yeah did you bring your inspection
face today Patrick Stewart um I brought
everything that could possibly legally
without offense be examined
no examination here today we're happy to
say but I love looking at you back then
in 1987 and now when you first took on
this role in 1987 did you have any
expectations You couldn't possibly have
thought it would go this long what were
your expectations back then well they
weren't High because I'd never heard of
Star Trek really
I had a very very quiet upbringing um I
I called my children because I knew they
watched something called star something
on Saturday afternoon as well and I once
or twice caught these guys in colored
t-shirts so I called them and said tell
me tell me because I got a got a meeting
today and I don't know whether I'm
meeting is about and uh I I talked to a
handful of people whom I knew and they
all said look you can't revive an iconic
show like Star Trek you're probably not
making the first season right so you
know make a little bit of money for the
first time in your life maybe you meet
some nice girls you know you can get a
suntan and go home yes I know several
years later I know and so how we sit
here 35 years later still talking about
it what does this character mean to you
I've been very blessed in my career with
the roles that I played
but nothing has the importance
like he's only for God and if you tell
me that I would be saying that when I
first got the role I would have laughed
in your face but as time went by and I
saw the impact that Star Trek could have
on people and their lives
um the diversity of the show it's belief
in honesty fair play equality all those
Elements which kind of get a little
sketchy in real these days in real life
in real life yeah there's other ways
that Star Trek has affected other people
but I'm interested in how it's affected
you where does the character End and You
Begin well I mean those are the lot
those are Picard and Patrick Stewart and
by season two they had done that and I
really didn't know where one began and
the other one left off I didn't have
arthritic fingers in those days of
course yeah it was much more comfortable
yeah
I
it changed my life there was nothing
in my life that was not affected and now
comes it comes to an end this Is It
season three the final season the final
Adventure
how do you feel about it you're smiling
yeah you're smiling you're smiling
you're expected of something aren't you
no it we have shot the final episode
there are no plans
for a future
but this is the thing about Star Trek
the nature of it you can't say it's over
right I mean look at there are five or
six different emanations of Star Trek
right on the air now the impact of the
show has been extraordinary I I was
talking with some people
a engineering and scientific research
place and they said do you have any idea
about the young people who are coming to
us now from universities who have gone
to college specifically to study
engineering or science or some kind of
you know experimental work and so many
of them mention Star Trek as being
behind their decision now that's
remarkable it is amazing and
particularly women young women are being
drawn into engineering
and
then they say it's because of the what
they experience bravo bravo can you ask
about the Memoir you've been working for
right last time we spoke you were in the
writing phase is the writing phase done
do we have a publication date the
writing is done I'm not working with a
brilliant man who is my Ed personal
editor David camp
and we are finessing
all the way through it's it's quite a
big book yeah yeah because it's my life
yes and there are a hundred or more
pages about Star Trek and X-Men but it's
not just about stuff yeah you've had
quite a life too no doubt Patrick I do
find it fascinating that she had low
expectations when you first
um attached to this brand that we like
to call Star Trek was there a particular
moment where you knew this was so much
bigger than what you realized
yes I was
um
almost at once when we began shooting
the first season of Star Trek
um
we were being invited to conventions and
and uh science fiction conventions
particularly and when I got there I was
taken into a back door and uh we were
waiting to begin and I was ready and uh
I said
is there anybody out there
and they said
well yes and I said oh well let's go
just checking that's all they announced
me and I walked on Wow and 2 000 people
Rose
began cheering and applauding and I was
utterly unexpected for that it was
incredible I love when you said you
walked out to a round of applause
because that is certainly how we feel
about you of course Applause continued
success hey what's left for you because
you know you were 80 something but you
still got a lot to get started yeah
um I well there there is a movie and uh
that's possible in the future but
principally I think the moment has come
when I'm gonna return to the life
theater to the stage all right in fact
there are a couple of Shakespeare roles
I've never played and wow and i i people
are talking about that now so that's
probably the next step you may be able
to get one without an audition I think
they might go around Tony maybe maybe
maybe Patrick Stewart thank you so much
congrats congrats for everything the
first episode of Star Trek Picard season
three the final is streaming now on
Paramount plus which as you know CBS is
a part of Paramount global